do you think after five months off
in your head you're sort of like three
months and you're like
you know danielle your wife
you know this um
did you ever go i could do another
season i mean
oh oh yeah all these months off i'm
gonna call the producers and let's go
let's get another one going
that was the longest that's the longest
uh break
break that i've had in 14 years from the
show that's what i'm saying
by the way longer than the writer's
strike in season three
wow that's which was what oh eight i
remember that
yeah yeah oh it was a weight yeah yeah
that's
you know it's also the longest i've ever
gone without traveling anywhere it's the
longest i've ever spent
as long as i've ever spent consecutively
with
your family with my family consecutively
so yeah i mean i'm certainly you know
certainly ready to go and and refreshed
and
and you know ready to get back to work
but
uh you know the ship has already sailed
on this being the last season
you know jared's already got another
show lined up uh i've got a few
stokers in the fire so um
you know we're uh we're going to knock
this out try to do it justice
i've you know i've always
i've always thought that there is a
possibility of you know five years down
the road getting the call and saying hey
let's
do a a little short order action for for
a streaming network and
bring them back for six episodes that's
gonna happen the show's too famous not
to happen
right i mean it'd be silly i mean it's
not like you guys are gonna age that
much in five years
i mean i it's been 10 years since i did
smallville but you know
i'm a little older but i you know lex
luthor could be able to still do it
i can still do it i'm older like i'll
shave or you know whatever but yeah you
guys could do that so it's always
there it's timeless it's something that
you guys could do
25 years from now hey what's going on
yeah can you believe we're still doing
this [ __ ] yep we are
and i do feel like this is this isn't
like the long goodbye right now
you know this is i feel like this is a
uh
uh you know let's let's put this
let's hang this in the closet for now
and and we'll we'll dust her off you
know down the road a bit
you